hello there and welcome to council of
geeks my name is Nathaniel Wayne it's
time for the roundtable and I'm joined
by just Ryan um hey I may do with what I
can get I've been called worse than just
Ryan so this is this is very true huh on
this very show interact so with this
being a month that is seeing the release
of two major films about magic users we
got Doctor Strange we've got fantastic
beasts and where to find them I just
thought we'd have a general discussion
about wizards in movies just kind of see
where this thing goes now I haven't seen
Doctor Strange yet because life keeps
happening I don't have the time and I
cook haven't seen this tonight why do I
have you over here oh just Ryan huh but
yes so I have not seen Doctor Strange oh
so we're not gonna talk about that at
the time of recording fantastic beasts
and where to find them hasn't been
released yet by the time I get this out
maybe it will have been but obviously we
haven't seen that either so this is this
is a more generalized comment and we'll
just see what this thing goes Ryan in
general wizards in movies when you
suggested this topic that I was telling
all right I don't know if I can really
think of a lot of wizards and then I
actually started putting my mind when I
was like there's actually a lot of great
wizards that I like from movies and
everything and I started doing like once
I got past the Gandalf and Dumbledore
although nothing against either of those
characters I'm like I start bouncing off
of all these different here so like I
really like that guy
so yeah it's they can be a source of you
know obviously you know dramatic like
odds by when you see a power used that
you haven't seen before in terms of
magic they can often be a source of
comedy because frequently they're old
white men yeah kind of mumbling and sort
of absent-minded despite having all
their powers so it does depend on how
they're used although I think a lot of
times they are used well yeah they can
be I mean I think you mentioned that the
duel elephants in the room which are
Dumbledore and Gandalf general thoughts
on these guys I do like them both i if I
had to take one I think I think Gandalf
is probably my favorite Wizard source
type of character in all of these
different movies there's just something
primordial about him he just feels like
the perfect distillation the the mold
everybody else coming he kind of is
he is of those two he's the more harder
edge I think Dumbledore is a little bit
like if you cross Gandalf with Santa
Claus you end up with Dumbledore now I
love Gandalf and now I am I
what about say i willfully called this
is nostalgia speaking I admit that my
prefer Gandalf is actually the animated
version from the 1970s The Hobbit movie
which was voiced by John Huston and it's
been about 30 years since I've seen it
so I could get John Huston voicing
Gandalf just give me some of those lines
yeah Ian McKellen was great and there's
no one else who I would have put in that
role at the time that mm-hmm the
live-action movie was made but John
Huston's voice is almost indescribable
and and that's at one point they have
they even have him reading like well in
the book their songs but they have him
reading lines of Tolkien poetry talking
about the dragon coming in and and it
just sounds so epic just to hear it
through his voice and there's something
about his Gandalf that feels a little
bit more dangerous than McKellen's
Gandalf a little bit like when Bilbo
first meets him he effectively just
calls down lightning until Bilbo to shut
up it's like whoa okay
I grew up on that sure no I'm not saying
it's objectively better but it kind of
it hits me a little more and my Gandalf
experience was very different cuz I know
I've seen the animated Hobbit but it
didn't leave the same lasting impression
of me I'm not a token reader I haven't
read The Lord of the Rings
I have tried three times it'll read The
Hobbit and I have never finished so when
I saw the Fellowship of the Ring I
really had no idea what I was getting
him for I kinda I had a general idea I'd
known I knew some of the names I knew
the basic bare-bones cloth but really
didn't know that much of it and Ian
McKellen surprised me a lot just with
the level of comedy but then partway
through when he takes out his sword and
he's got a sword and his staff when he's
on the region he slams the
down and calls out about right you shall
not pass I was like I've never seen a
wizard like this this is we're on a
different level and just go succeeded
the movies after that with the other the
next two just seeing him fight see him
it's like that is because he presents
such a sort of stately up until that
point a very sort of wizened he just
seems more intellectual more cerebral
but once you see him fighting like no
this is a guy who has earned you know
every breath he's taken in his 1,000
years of life or something well so
initially because when I think about it
wizards have a tendency to fill a
background sort of dairy they're a
living resource they tend to be a living
resource of either knowledge or like a
very specific use of power but it's very
rare that their front and center for
what you mentioned early on which is
that they tend to skip the scales so
much that it becomes overpowered issue
the Dumbledore very much takes a
backbone the world pretty much every
depiction of Merlin is more of a
background role my own preferred Merlin
is from sorting so I was gonna bring
that one up too I made my list like my
top three was just wake up I was like I
love that Merlin look at the owl
Archimedes he beats madam MIM and it
like a duel like a triangle like turning
into a journey that that is my personal
favorite magical duel yes
and in case you haven't seen sort of
this sword in the stone the idea is that
rather than like throwing fireballs at
each other they turn themselves into
different creatures and different
animals they had a tree like she can
turn into any flick pink dragons or
something because she turns into a
purplish yes but he goes where she goes
how he goes small turns into a German
which is also kind of bending the rules
go ahead but he did turn into a living
thing but he turned into a disease and
made her bedridden who did not disappear
he just went microscopic oh yeah I love
that depiction of Berlin - that is my
favorite and well I love the whole thing
that Merlin's kind of living his life in
Reverse so he keeps talking he's so
frustrated back in the Middle Ages cuz
he knows what the future is like and all
the stuff that he doesn't have like
indoor plumbing
all this something he knows will exist
but he's stuck without it and I love
that frustration yeah um now here's
something that right because I thought
about willow it's not necessarily a
great movie but it made me realize
something which is that you there are
movies about wizards there are movies
about magicians rarely do the two cross
paths and they kind of do in the form of
willow and the reason they don't mix is
generally you're either dealing with
magic is real or magic isn't right and
when you're dealing with magicians it's
all fake it's all illusion are you doing
with Wizards magic it's real
but willow is interesting because this
is a world with Matt right and there are
wizards but our titular character is
more of a sleight of hand
yeah he he's a magician I mean he
actually wins by doing exactly a
sleight-of-hand trick which I kind of
love it's perfect one of the really
strong things about a movie that is I
think better than a lot of people give
it credit for but isn't it's not a great
movie but I do kind of like that mixing
of real magic and fake magic because it
doesn't happen a whole lot and another
thing that willow is it seems to sort of
flip the genre if you look at something
like The Hobbit or the Lord of the Rings
or sort of the stone where as you said
the wizard is more of a resource
character he's more of the sidekick or
the mentor to help our warrior character
there are more sort of physical action
type of hero on his journey
willow is almost the reverse mad mardian
is our sword fighting like warrior care
in society and he is the sign of our
aspiring young wizard sorcerer magician
character so it doesn't it's a nice
little flip it's funny the movies that
the more I think about it the more I
love almost every idea and concept of a
heart of it it's just it didn't quite
hit everything at the level it needed to
to really drive it all home and that's
something else we talked about sort of
the iconography of certainly Wizards the
look of them and how the yeah nourish
themselves well God the Hat a funny hat
and a beard is kind of the thing but I
can take something the complete opposite
directions sort of still like the robes
but ditch the Hat ditch the beard and
look at a character in the Harry Potter
movies Severus Snape mm-hmm well I think
steals the show and he would
my favorite wizard in those movies play
no no small part due to Alan Rickman's
performance being able to sort of like
enjoy other people's pain this
schadenfreude that's it doesn't seem
malicious it seems like just sort of
there's just like so much hate inside
them he he the impression I n of him is
the world has crapped on him so much he
enjoys seeing a crap on somebody else
for once yeah yeah and he makes magic
look effortless which whether that's
part of the character of the performance
or what he interpreted I mean it is it
is sort of based in the micro world
where magic isn't really special in the
world yeah but all of your characters
have it well certainly compared to the
younger characters who you and was one
of the things that was really good about
that you can see it looks like it's hard
right when the kids do it but then you
have someone like say just back a spell
that was cast away like like it like
he's swatting a fly actually has to
Train Harry to do something and it's oh
boy yeah you never want to teach her
like that no also thinking about the the
fashion and sort of the look of wizards
and sorcery characters I mean I gotta go
with I don't know his name but there are
some who call him Tim it's crazy is John
Cleese it's yeah he's got big ram's horn
so yeah Justin gays anyone be Hat beard
yeah funny happy in case anyone didn't
catch the reference we're talking about
John Cleese playing Timothy enchanting
the enchanter little doll and one of the
most inconsistent accents ever put like
sometimes he is so Scottish and
sometimes I think Charlie's just
forgotten what an eccentric performance
did you see Howl's Moving Castle I did
not he is young and handsome and a
complete coward like his whole deal
the reason his castle moves is so that
the local king can't find him to
conscript him into the army it's
questionable how much of his issue is
cowardice and how much of it is like
conscientious of direct objector it's
probably six of one half dozen of the
other
he's almost an obstacle as much as a
companion to the main character just
because he's so focused on himself and
has so little regard for what else is
going on
one of the general things I kind of like
about magic as opposed to when things
get more quote-unquote grounded you know
with when it comes to questions of like
sci-fi versus fantasy i10 I think
aesthetically I like sci-fi better
mm-hmm but storytelling I favor fantasy
because fantasy does not feel the need
to over explain itself and when you deal
with magic I kind of I kind of like
being embroiled in a world that I know
is bigger than I will ever understand
and I cut in that magic by its nature
kind of is that because it always seems
like wizards are they are playing by
rules but I don't know what they are and
you don't need to yes immortal what I
don't need to know what their rules are
they just work right because magic yeah
I tend to favor sci-fi for a lot of the
same reasons but I guess when it come a
bit yeah I'm also able to just sort of
understand that when magic comes out I
don't need to know the mechanics and
there aren't supposed to be mechanics of
its yeah I'm able to suspend my
disbelief in that state with science
fiction I think part of the science in
there is okay there are rules there are
certainly you know physical properties
that even if I don't know them I
understand that there is a rule for all
of this stuff and with fantasy it's like
no with magic think it doesn't have to
be a rule so it kind of breaks the rules
that's the whole point of it we
really talk that much about Harry Potter
and that universe I think that one of
the strengths of that series was
throwing it like taking it over where
virtually anything is possible and when
you've got a cast of dozens of
characters who can do extraordinary
things but putting them through natural
sort of paces and struggles and
obstacles I'm just going to school for
this and figure out what that actually
means and witnessing what it takes to
actually be good at something like this
it the more you think about that series
the the fact that they had that it's
paced the way it is through these these
seven years of school or six years of
school and one in and one year of
backpacking in the woods split into two
movies Roger that actually does a lot to
defer the problems that can come with
having characters dealing magic because
it forces the learning progression to be
to be steady but slow and it also means
that we're focusing on characters who
can't do everything yet and I think that
was a really smart way again to sort of
work around the potential narrative
breaking problems that that magic can
introduce I guess one other just cuz
it's a movie that I keep meaning to do
anime animation junkie episode on and I
know you probably haven't seen it almost
nobody has have you seen the movie
Wizards Ralph Bakshi late seventies
movie it's a movie that was really
important to me in terms of my
appreciation of animation and kind of
why I never grew out of it because I saw
it I think in seventh grade and it was
violent and it was it was sort of this
way overall like I don't have to have a
bro animation there is animation out
there that I continued can can't
continue to enjoy even though I'm too
old for Disney yeah so it was an
important phone me and doesn't hold up
the way I wish it did going back and
watching it but it's an interesting
concept because it's actually
technically it's a post-apocalyptic okay
movie
because it's set in the future where the
human race has wiped itself out via
nuclear annihilation
what humans are left are badly mutated
and basically after the humans are
effectively gone fairies and dwarves and
elves and wizards when oh great we can
come back now and so it's it's a more or
less standard fantasy world but there
are guns and tanks and whatever around
but they're ancient artefact okay being
used by the villain and his army the
titular wizards are there's avatar and
black wolf who are actually brothers
again it's one of those ones with some
cool ideas and but in an odd way
very little straight-up magic from the
actual Wizards because they're more in
leadership roles but just sort of an
island that I wanted I work because the
title is Wizards well I'm gonna do my
diatribe about the Fred Savage a
Nintendo movie the wizard go ahead oh
you're the floor you actually want to
talk about it found oh so you had
mentioned that you actually did kind of
put together or like a top three or
something were there any that we didn't
already talked about ah
no I would have had Merlin from the
sword in the stone
probably number three Snape at two and
Dan off at number one with Tim The
Enchantress as the floating either
runner-up or number one sort of
depending on what move had then and I
consider that fair even though I
arranged this
I didn't bother with top three because
I'm not that organized um so yeah this
tis the month of wizards at the movie
theater and we talked about not the ones
in the movie theater so why are you
listening to this again what's wrong
with you go outside do something with
your time and thank you for tuning in um
so thank you very much
Ryan thank you for having me so if
you're watching this on youtube you can
listen to the whole uncut conversation
on the council of geeks podcast
available on itunes and stitcher but in
any case this council is adjourned